hi guys it's a read again and I've got
some news for you I've decided to get
rid of my tutorial channel well not
really get rid of it but just quit it
because I wasn't doing anything on it
anymore because I was too busy with this
channel and having a tutorial channel
was kind of ridiculous anyway wasn't
wasn't really useful at all I mean I
could have just done the tutorials in
this channel and it's all complicated
stuff anyway I just want to do
everything in this channel now and get
rid of all the confusion going on so
what I want to start off with is a
tutorial about stuff that actually made
my channel a lot bigger lately because
I've done my let's play Park of course
and I've got all these classical
buildings in it neoclassical to be exact
and I've just caught this video
classical building tutorial just because
classical is just a more common word for
it and that's exactly what I'm going to
show you today so we're gonna start off
with turning on the grid because it's
just very handy and there's one set
which you're really going to love when
it comes to this kind of stuff that
wasn't intended and it's called
Ralphie's antique world and people kept
asking me what said I used for my
classic buildings well 99% of it is it's
just this set it's amazing but and well
we're going to start off with the
foundation for our building and I want
to have a simple building just a simple
temple ish building with the dome on top
of it and I want to start off with
layout plan so I'm going to do that as
follows so this is the layout plan for
my small building and now we're going to
continue using these wall bottom posts
and place them every other and place
them on every single square so like this
all right now so these are the
foundations for all of our pillars so
we're going to go ahead and play some
pillar bottoms wherever we want pillars
and also be Luster's because they have
bottoms just like normal pillars so
we've got this now and this might look a
bit awkward so I'm going to go ahead and
place the floor now just raising a level
and just use the floor that's in this
pack it's perfect for this kind of stuff
alright so now it's time for the pillars
and pillars off about 8 meters high is
generally what I think looks good so I'm
doing that right now
so now we've got this and it's starting
to look like something good and now we
want to build the pilasters and you want
to built them like this and this might
look a little bit weird but they always
have to be one edge higher than the
pillars at this point and you'll see
later on why Surovell be the last of
them and I've just decided that I want
to have a cool exit as well so I'm just
going to put a few pillows in here
because basically it works like this if
you've got an open space you have to
work with pillars and if you have
pillars that are actually connected to a
wall they have to be plasters and they
have to be square like that at least
that's where it works like in real life
and now we're going to go ahead and add
some tops now we've got top one which
looks like this looks like this on a
normal pillar and looks like that on a
pedestrian and then we've got top two
which I kind of like which looks like
this it just has that little I don't
know square thing underneath it which I
really like about it so I'm going to go
ahead and use that one not remove that
the last two hold up now a tip for this
just press shifts and then control and
raise it up to the height you want to
have it and it will stay there so this
is something you can easily do in well a
short amount of time so that is that and
it's time to add a front door and
there's a really nice door in this set
which is this one it even has a cool
frame it's not too hard to make see it's
easily done and placed and I'm going to
have the door I'm going to have two
doors in this side on the sides actually
oh and I just realized I forgot a few
pilasters so I'm going to have to place
though
okay now I'll fill these places in with
some Brown walls just for a little bit
of well know a different shade of brown
just put a little bit of contrast
actually in there this is going to be
like a baroque style building I mean
there are different types of classical
architecture and when it comes to new
ways of dealing with it so there's also
a lot of ways you can be creative with
this but there's just this one general
style which I like which is just
messing about and trying whatever looks
best that looks pretty good I think I'm
going to use the smaller when there
isn't top floor though think this is
going to be a building with two floors
and we're going to have a top floor like
this and about some floor with these
windows for now I'm just going to fill
this I'm just going to fill the gaps in
and place these windows everywhere all
right so the walls are finished I know
you might think well that looks like one
ugly block of the building and it sure
does but the roof is actually one of the
most important things of classical
architecture so we're going to tackle
that now start off with these large
roofs and this gets kind of complicated
so I'll explain it first you start with
these roofs and when you've got corners
like this you're going to take the roof
large three sites plus and place them
around all the corners and then you're
done with that and you're going to take
there one side plus and then fill in the
rest that that's how it works but after
this you're not done yet but I'll show
that in a minute so now we've placed
this roof everywhere but it still
doesn't look very good and I'm still
closing the gap in the middle over here
now the way classical architecture works
though is you've got the pillows and the
pillows supports two layers of roof
first we've got the architrave I think
and then we've got the frieze and we're
going to do the frieze right now and it
works exactly in the same way as the
first layer does and you just put it on
top of it and same process again so I'm
going to save you that time and just
skip to watch the end now this is what
you'll have done and if you look at it
from the side you can really see that it
already has that classical theming to it
but it's not finished yet now for the
roof I like to use rct3 Adams
birthname Manor I'm pretty sure it's
called yeah and basically I like to use
it because it has this really cool roof
which is over here let's go with a rat
roof I always like to have a roof with a
very different color than the rest of
the building and we're just going to
place this roof all over the
and when it comes to this roof and
corners you just use these corners for
the cornice alright so the roof is
finished but what I'm doing now is
placing roof trims on top of the roof
because I really like these trims that
are included in the rct3 Adam's birthday
manner sets and they're just a little
detail for it to place on top of the
roof and they just make it look a little
bit better and it's just a little bit of
eye candy and eye candy when it comes to
classical architecture is always good
because it's all about the eye candy and
one more tip when it comes to roofs
always always just add some dormers even
if it looks if it well might look
awkward dormers are always a nice detail
to add two roofs if you've got nothing
else to add so now we're almost finished
with the building itself all we still
need to do is place down the roof on top
of the building and then the only thing
that's really left to do is the dome so
I'm going to do this real quick and then
do the dome alright so here comes the
tricky part
we're going to start off with showing
guys planters one which is actually a
path cover SATs well not really a path
cover set it's a sap meant for fences
for paths and even as flowers in it and
all that kind of stuff but I really like
the texture of it and it has curves and
curves is just what we need for the dome
so just make sure to have a three H
little round thing on the roof I don't
even know what to call this because this
is the starting point for the rest of
the dome now we're going to open station
jim's
church things I didn't even know that is
the name of the SATs station jim's
chapel building - because it has really
cool windows in it here are these ones
and also plenty of other stuff that
we're going to use later on but first we
need some windows in here so just place
windows all around and that won't be it
however because we need to play some
pillars in here now luckily this set
also has these pillars in there so take
these pillars that one concrete posts a
and just place them around these think
yeah you can place them
about 4-h even if their walls itself
were just three H because we're going to
add something on top of this but you'll
see later on what it is okay so this set
has two trims in it it's got a trim B
and a trim a and we're gonna start off
with trim a I'm gonna put it in the
bottom here because we want this little
line as you see here this little line
connecting it to the roof and it even
connects it to those supports as well
and then trim B is going to be placed on
top of that over here now I know various
at with various trims but you can if
you're lazy just use trim B for both of
these trims because you're gonna want
this little sort of freeze thing on the
top because there's no real Brown trees
in rct3 but we can kind of want to
create that idea so we're going to use
this and then we're going to open mobis
curved walls and I'm going to include
links of all of this stuff in the
description don't worry about it and
we're going to choose this brown color
that we've been using all over the place
and just add these walls in there we're
going to place pillars in like this so
three four times three pillows in a row
yeah that's easily done and then we're
just going to add another top when it
comes to tops of pillows I always like
to use the same top all over the place
in one building don't use different tops
or different bottoms or different kinds
of pillows in one building because one
building tends to follow one type of
style and now we're going to open
station gym set again and go to the
domes and as you can see here there's a
nice little dome and we're going to
place it on top of that and hopefully
it's all going to work out yes it works
out perfectly and now the dome is almost
finished I always like to add one little
extra thing which is sometimes they have
a cross on top of it sometimes it's just
something else I like to use this and
we're going to start out with a wall
bottom post it takes to be able to try
on arrow to get it in right in there
that won't kind of
quick and then we're going to take a
post and then we're going to take a
balustrade post and now I'll give you
this so I think that looks pretty cool
now there's of course you can also add
or miss to do route to the dome let me
do that real quick
all right so that's the building now
it's pretty much finished but the you
can of course add a few finishing
touches that I really like to add for
example you can add some ballast trades
on the bottom here let me get this up
real quick
Bela straight four and just place them
all over the bottom here and then of
course you can also make these wall
bottoms a little bit longer
add some posts in here and add some more
bottoms in there and then what you can
do is for example you take a sculpture
of Zeus apparently Zeus like looks like
this and have some nice corpses in there
or whatever you like to have in there
for example you can also add a witch in
McCall it's it's a fountain I knew
there's a front in here somewhere
are there it is fountains for example I
really like fountains and other stuff
now there's one little thing that I
almost forgot about and that's a
pediment a lot of classic buildings have
a pediment and I didn't add one yet
because I think this building looks
really good without one but if you like
it you can add one works like this you
just place it on top of the fries and
then you take a roof like this one a
roof tile pitched large or a roof
pitched large and I think I'm going for
a mmm pitched one and I mean a non tiled
one basically and then just place that I
think not sure if this looks too good
it's decent though I guess you could
also just add nothing in there but that
looks okay though I don't like the view
from the side and you can also just
extent this one this this roof and get
rid of this one and then at these but
that's all up to your own tastes this is
the basic building right here and that
was the tutorial I hope you enjoyed it
and see you next time